you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
in the last episode we looked at the
origins of both iOS and Android it was
an interesting episode that allows you
to understand the full context of this
video the previous video will be the
first link in the description below so
be sure to check out that video before
you start watching this one if you don't
start from the last video you're just
not getting the full story in this
episode we'll take a look at the app
environment unique features security
risks brand effectiveness and features
of both Android and iOS let's continue
with this episode we'll begin with the
app environment one of the most critical
aspects of a mobile OS currently Android
leads in terms of the sheer number of
apps available but only just Android has
1.5 million apps versus iOS is 1.4
million with Windows Phone lagging
behind at 3,400 it's not just about the
number of apps though iOS tends to get
premium titles first which is important
to some Android on the other hand has an
abundance of third-party apps for every
activity you could imagine take a nap
like Tasker for example it's a
relatively simple app that allows you to
program your phone to do almost anything
but why does all of this exist for
Android why is this so enter the Android
community Android strong community of
developers and tech enthusiasts really
Drive the platform the open source
nature of Android allows this to happen
freely and as a result everyone benefits
if you decide to start modding your
Android phone then the help information
and tools are out there and freely
available ok so why would you want to
modify your phone by routing or adding
custom roms in the first place popular
reasons include installing alternative
versions of Android removing bloatware
or overclocking the hardware to get more
performance out of it even without
reading Android is incredibly flexible
if you want you can personalize your
device beyond your wildest dreams
this includes homescreen replacements
live boxes here where you can change the
look and feel of your phone instantly
all of that being said the complete open
is both a blessing and a curse for
Android here's the downside since
Android is completely open and can work
on any hardware from a card to a fridge
by definition it's impossible to
optimize the software as perfectly as
Apple does Apple on the other hand knows
every minor detail in the hardware of
every phone model that they've ever
created and has the corresponding
firmware for it
controlling the production of both the
software and hardware can be described
by the term vertical integration of
which Steve Jobs was fond of one of the
pioneers of our industry Alan Kay has
had a lot of great quotes throughout the
years and I ran across one of them
recently that explains how we look at
this explains why we go about doing
things the way we do because we love
software and here's the quote people who
are really serious about software should
make their own hard now Allen said this
30 years ago and this is how we feel
about it and so we're bringing
breakthrough software to a mobile device
for the first time this vertical
integration allows for complete control
and optimization so much so that one
gigabyte of RAM is more than enough for
the smooth running of an Apple device as
most of you would know one gig of ram
coupled with a run-of-the-mill processor
isn't enough for Android these days
you're going to run into some
performance issues at that level this
kind of situation has resulted in many
people's first experience of Android
being a negative one however as shown in
the previous video the most powerful
Android phones are usually more
responsive than the corresponding iPhone
all right so so far we're seeing that
both iOS and Android have improved
greatly over time but let's take this a
step further what are the exact features
that set both OS is apart
so now that I phones have larger screens
and more features what things truly
stand out on Android well in Android you
have an access to a file system just
like a computer so this is extremely
useful for managing downloaded files
from a website you have the ability to
set default apps so you can customize
the phone's behavior you can add a
launcher to completely change the look
and feel of your phone there's widgets
on your home screen
so you can have information that's
important to you displayed it within
reach USB on-the-go
mouse support HDMI support through an
external monitor and the list goes on
and could be endless in theory iMessage
a free messaging service integrated
across most Apple devices elegant
attention to detail in terms of design
language and animation this FaceTime a
free video communication service
exclusive to Apple devices
there's airdrop which enables the
transfer of documents among supported
Mac computers and iOS devices and then
of course the seamless Apple ecosystem
integration which is great if you own a
lot of Apple products but it's a
nightmare otherwise so now that we're
clear on the details of the uniqueness
of both operating systems let's change
gears a little bit and move on to
something increasingly more important
these days security a lot of people use
their phones for everything when they're
on the go this includes activities such
as online banking and sensitive email
with hackers knowing this knowledge
mobile security is becoming a real issue
today last year a company called beyond
trust managed to find 127 security flaws
in iOS one of which allowed spyware
versions of apps like Facebook and Skype
to get onto iOS devices but the story is
probably a lot worse for Android the
total number of security flaws in
Android could be even higher than iOS
but nobody actually knows for sure
because OEMs like
HTC Samsung and wireless carriers are
free to customize the OS even changing
default applications as they see fit
that being said though this year
research has found a gaping
vulnerability in Android cold
stage-fright stagefright
allows a hacker to take complete control
of an Android
or tablet leaving almost 1 billion
devices at risk in response to stage
fright
Google and other phone manufacturers are
sending out monthly security patches
independent of software updates although
it seems like Android definitely comes
out on top in its uniqueness there's
still some drawbacks mainly I'm talking
about the extremely slow stuttering
software updates Google's Nexus range is
usually the first to receive a software
update but other customers are left out
in the cold for a bit too long this is
mainly because device manufacturers have
to take the time to incorporate the new
software into their own UI which adds
further delay iOS on the other hand it
usually has the latest version of its
operating system in compatible devices
within the first month so looking at all
that we've covered there's one thing
that sways in the favor of the iPhone
and it's something that Android perhaps
may never have and that is a strong
brand no also mention Android Lezyne
open an iPhone and check out the iOS
native Android APIs for chill day
another turn at its collector outside
it's the item or bottom dead battery so
now I'm that first snail NFL soup flavor
in my opinion it does look but I would
recommend together and if I could get
one myself I would it can apologize
conveyed over the decades
Apple has had the ability to turn the
ordinary into something beautiful almost
invoking an emotional response in the
end user their advertising
tends to allude to their products being
so much more than what they physically
are they sell dreams and ideas with
beautiful industrial design from Johnny
if2 boo they communicate in a language
that everyone understands there's no
mention of gigahertz or Ram it's all
about descriptive terms like edge to
edge glass Retina Display iSight camera
this is endowed the company with one of
the strongest brand images in history in
short the iPhone is now a cultural icon
a recognizable status symbol something
that Android in general may never
achieve but why is this the fact is that
there's just too many devices and
software skins for consumers to have one
crystal clear brand
which Android represents freedom and
choice but it's somewhat of a hard sell
due to the cognitive dissidence caused
by that very same factor of choice for
example I've actually heard people say
that they couldn't decide which Android
phone to get so they just got an iPhone
ok so we're almost at the end of the
video but we fully move on to the
conclusions let's examine the possible
features of both iOS and Android so
what's next for Android and iOS it's
hard to completely say but a clear trend
is starting to emerge the table shown
here depicts the buying habits of mobile
phone consumers over the past couple of
years what this table is saying is that
from the end of 2013 to the middle of
2015
82 percent of participants of the survey
stayed with Android and 78 percent
stayed with Apple so what does this mean
well in basic terms were starting to see
market saturation in the Western world
and this is a sign of market maturity
basically everyone that wanted a
smartphone pretty much has one and
frankly these days if you're not an
enthusiast it's unsustainable for you to
keep going out there and playing a new
phone every six months or a year while
older flagships are starting to become
good enough to hold on to so what's the
bottom line people are happier to stay
with each platform the rivalry is
starting to tail off some of you
observant viewers would have noted that
I said that those are saturation in the
Western market Google sees what's coming
Android has recently started pushing
towards the developing market this is
evident by androids recent push of
Android one a strong nexus tile brand in
emerging markets in addition to this
Android software openness could benefit
them in the realm of driverless cars
smart homes and beyond on the other hand
iPhones may get split screen eventually
and also properly keep the dual size
format and rely on their brand strength
apple's foray into the automotive
industry will be something interesting
to keep an eye on if the Apple car does
in fact materialize and if it runs iOS
apart from these things that I've
mentioned it's quite difficult to say
with any certainty what's going to
happen in the future with these two
so with that said let's move on to the
conclusions the software elegance
premium brand ease of use and simplicity
of Apple's iOS has done it wonders it's
an international icon of status and
social trend awareness vertical
integration has also made the platform
secure stable and predictable Android
has come a very very long way since its
inception it's now responsive and
polished with freedom choice
personalization and a feature-rich
environment it has been the industry
springboard for startups like oneplus to
come in and push the whole industry
forward this is great for consumers so
which one is better that's not the right
question to be asking that's like asking
what is the best food in the world it's
obviously going to depend on who you ask
and their preferences iOS appeals to a
group of people who have certain demands
and needs from technology while Android
appeals to a group of people that may or
may not be mutually exclusive to those
who prefer iOS for the majority of users
both operating systems do the same thing
fulfill their technology needs so the
score is settled and it's one or
for me personally I prefer Android
because I can do whatever I like here's
what I mean for those of you have been
following my channel for a while you
know that this channel started off with
customization back in 2011 I discovered
a combination of apps that could get
your phone to look like no one had ever
seen before at the time and that's how
this channel really started in other
words without Android this channel would
not exist as it does today and you
wouldn't be seeing this video and
besides features like multitasking and
access to the file browser are just too
hard to live without but of course
that's just me anyway guys thanks for
watching don't forget to give this video
a thumbs up share it comment and
subscribe if you're new this has been -
go go you have been watching cold fusion
and I'll see you again for the next
video cheers guys have a good one hi
guys - go go yeah it's going - thank you
guys for watching the whole way through
that video it's quite interesting when
you think about how Android and iOS have
evolved over time and how both of them
nowadays serve the same purpose
they both fulfill the technological
needs of the user so it's interesting
just to see that come to fruition in
2015 as a side point I also want to
thank you guys for all your support and
all your kind comments over the years
and even recent weeks and months because
the channel has seen quite a bit of
growth this year and it's just really
amazing to see that you guys so support
it was just incredible so it really
means a lot to me I just wanted to thank
you guys personally and I've got some
interesting stuff coming up in there
some future coming videos so stay tuned
if you're new here feel free to
subscribe and share this to a friend
someone who's interested in Android or
iOS and I'll see you again soon for the
next video so until next time everyone
depending on the users me
ColdFusion its rethinking it's also
personal to a large percentage of the
population who own a smartphone the most
personal device of all this is part one
of a two part series on Android versus
iOS in these videos